[Music]
welcome back to careful woods we are
very careful boys
today we got gilbert gilbert look at his
eyebrows he's like oh [ __ ] is this
what's up gail oh you guys have weird
energies huh what do you mean you got
weird eyebrows i was on the youtubes and
i kept saying this word on your all's
faces that said careful boys yeah yeah
yeah it's sick right yeah are you trying
to get merch right now free merch
because we're not going to give a free
merch dude we're still working on the
[ __ ] logo dude yeah what is careful
boys on the [ __ ] slope we gotta be
careful man cause these days what have
you ever been careful in your life i'm
very careful i'm one of the safest
people here are you
just talk to we just talked about how
you fly or die in your financials
you got your back right now but
literally how so
i wanna get your back but also just give
me more explanation yeah yeah yeah okay
but it's not about me it's about the
world today okay today
this climate makes it so that i have to
watch my words
everyone here has to watch their work
it's called climate change you know it's
it's dangerous we're doing it for
climate change
yeah
for global [ __ ] warming dude wait did
people uh push back on anything no
because okay so so you know this channel
right it's got [ __ ] so hard because we
got flagged for some old content
almost got deleted off of youtube
and then now we had to be careful
that's why we're careful boys
you have to be careful it's just them
talking about like what punting a baby
off a bridge or something
literally nothing is that what you guys
got in trouble for no okay
it always got so serious man it was
[ __ ] talking about
back in the day when we did jk news we
used to play videos and react to them
right and there was a video of
surveillance footage of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's a toddler playing and he
ran up and he kicked that [ __ ] baby
like a football goal no way yeah where
was this
china oh look at how plays it again i'll
show you guys
what happens let's play it again we're
gonna say something gil you were like
well anthony was smiling you're like he
punted a baby it's legit it makes sense
can i laugh see i like like a [ __ ]
funny ass word dude this is like it was
a punch oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] he just like gamified it
baby was like being kicked through this
thing right here but then our second
warning they would have took down the
whole channel which is what made us
careful so we're trying to be careful in
this new you wouldn't understand but
don't people do a lot of reaction videos
like that of crazy [ __ ] i think they
violate youtube terms man i don't know
why but also you know what really [ __ ]
us over is because it was also in the
playlist so then they flagged the same
[ __ ] video on the playlist and said
we got two strikes three strikes you out
yeah these bots don't know how to
differentiate two it's true don't you
have any youtube connections no we did
and they say sorry we can't control the
bots man [ __ ] youtube robots control
youtube they lost control of their own
algorithm yeah i've heard that many
times they can't control their [ __ ]
they can't do it no more jesus
oh my god on the other side of the
camera someone's doing this
there it is oh my god that's in china
that's that's gotta be fake as [ __ ] no
man that's a real one y'all
and we might be
going back on page we might be going
back on patreon guys [ __ ]
well and also that you know these things
sort of react to that one again react to
this oh dude wouldn't you agree that
today
we can't make the same jokes as we did
in 2016. can you make the same jokes in
three years from now or is it worse yeah
dude yeah like which direction does it
go it's gonna get more massive do you
actually i think it's gonna get crazier
i think it's gonna be way more fun
in terms of it gets more [ __ ] it's
already fun it's must get way more
baby
scratch on the surface dude
or a [ __ ] more patreon videos
chapelle sets are getting softer and
softer though that's true and he's
getting he's trying to get they're
trying to cancel his ass for being soft
yeah i'm like weird this old [ __ ] was
way more hardcore but like even with
comedians you see them kind of
transition from like like prolific ones
like they they have great stand up and
they have like really cool sets but as
they get older they kind of
their their comedy kind of changes a
little bit like like george carlin like
at the end of his career he was kind of
more like
doing like advice and like talking about
like life a lot more it's like he does
more tech talks now yeah humor thrown in
honest question though is that like an
improvement on society or
i i can understand what it does to
comedy in a way that's like less funny
but like in an actual like hive
mentality of like what's supposed to be
better for society that's crossover i
think you're right i think comedians
write their life so
in the beginning you're like angry at
the world right like everyone is like
whether in all art forms you're young
and spunky and then once you have kids
you have family like you're you know
like kevin hart only writes family
comedy yeah it's what my kid does what
my mom does or my wife does what her top
just talks about his life what's his
life
it's props he never changed for anybody
yeah well he doesn't change so i guess
it stays the same but
i remember someone saying if comedians
start adjusting what you already see it
now especially with younger ones they're
scared they start adjusting their humor
to appease a crowd or whatever society's
saying that you're [ __ ] because
comedians are supposed to be like the
parakeet in the coal mine so guess what
these comedians got to pay their goddamn
bills gills gills in a way they are the
canary in the coal mine because they're
dying and then everyone's going oh [ __ ]
we gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
[Laughter]
there is no lie
rose how about that have you done stand
up in a while no never why no i did it
once and uh i did it for bobby what was
your set are you open from you might
know my set well i don't know i don't
it's i'll unlock i need to take it off
we're going to be just doing an ace x
the whole time and they [ __ ]
destroyed
well good it did good [ __ ] it
this was six years ago i think when uh
they were talking about idris elba uh
gonna be the new like james bond so i
was like i literally just straight went
up that fan the whole time i was like
what if an asian guy was james bond and
basically just said james boss lies
james tran [ __ ] yeah
oh my gosh
improv is like all like latinos and they
just love
asian humor
laughing at asians yeah they just love
laughing at us yeah that's great dude
you know latins we don't even have to
say nothing and they'll just laugh at us
yeah like we could walk down the street
like nick this [ __ ] happened to mexico
and nick he was walking down the street
they said chino and they started dying
bro they gave him five dollars they're
like ah
hey tell me another joke fool
and there was other asian people there
but they just singled me out like here's
ten dollars got a bigger shirt
that shirt is so tight why is your shirt
so tight
this is carlos smith
the [ __ ] dude
bro that guy's gone huh then ned holding
this some people are gonna rub it in at
all times that guy's a god man [ __ ]
hey poor
dead what the crazy thing is is uh [ __ ]
man we did uh when he came out in tiger
belly i remember bobby was like that was
probably the most nervous he's ever been
uh for a podcast because they got beef
kind of right you guys got carlos back
on right yeah like recently the big
thing was because uh remember bob the
big thing for bobby was like everyone
said he was in a hostage situation when
carlos apparently made him go on camera
after the whole joe rogan thing and was
like bobby you need to tell people i
don't steal jokes it's like funny
because bobby's literally wants him to
tell lies that's kind of what what
happens bobby tried to confront him
about that yeah try to but he's not a
very confronted person did he do a good
job he actually did a good job there's
like 10 comedians that say carlos steals
jokes there's a lot
timing too like word for word and the
timing and the delivery and the voice
you use the voice dude
you wear the cosby sweater
this is gonna be weird because my next
joke is gonna be in the voice of bill
cosby
depression it's an impression but the
question is did they laugh and assume it
was his he killed he killed it oh he
killed him he killed monetized off it
probably that's probably the biggest
dude remember there was a time where
carlos messier was like the biggest
comic he had the tv yeah the show yeah
he was everywhere like didn't george
lopez punch him yeah he punched him for
stealing jokes i liked that show too
yeah george lopez he said he was
stealing jokes so he went up to him and
approached him and punched him in the
face did he get his jokes back after
that nope
there's still his jokes come out after
you punched him
[ __ ] joke stealing [ __ ] you saw this
one clip of uh joe rogan confront team
mencia back in the day oh the original
the original one
he's like up next to him like this and
i'm like damn do you like in mancil was
acting hard and i'm like you know this
guy will [ __ ] kill your ass right and
i almost wanted to see him beat his ass
but he was just i guess such a good
martial artist that he was just
contained i hate the good martial artist
bro i want to see some technique out
there on this
yeah
sloppy ass fight videos
you guys are the ones who are always
talking about i don't even know what i'm
looking at ever but you guys are always
like nah that technique sucks and i was
like i guess yeah
so i want to see a finally like a real
fighter in one of these there was one
video that was pretty uh
like famous recently but it's kind of
like i don't know if this guy should
have punched him he's a very famous muay
thai kickboxer
joe schilling he's walking in a bar
that got this drunk guy is like dude
he's obliterated he bumps into him
and then the drunk guy turns to joe
schilling he's like talking [ __ ] and he
says
like one hitter quitters
just falls out and then just walks away
but it looks like part of me when you
watch it you're like was he instigating
that like did he [ __ ] bump into i
wasn't annoyed and he wanted to a little
bit he want to punch him in the [ __ ]
head but this video went or was it just
the worst accident ever
just [ __ ] could be both nobody knows
my bad man boom but yeah dude he lit him
the [ __ ] up and but he's someone that
like knows how to punch and he probably
punched 10 percent you're like holy [ __ ]
he got [ __ ] up
in the real video it's very similar like
that yeah like it's very similar well at
least
yeah
the tragedy dude you're gonna get us
canceled again we gotta be careful
today's video is brought to you by star
it's nearly thanksgiving and if you have
debt let me give you guys something to
be grateful for upstart upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
you're paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment all online
upstart knows that you're more than just
a credit score and is expanding access
to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan you can see
your rate upfront for loans between one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payment today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use that
url so they know that we sent you guys
loan amounts will be determined by your
credit income and other certain
information that you put on your loan
application go to upstart.com off the
record
okay
this is what is actually that's it
that's it do you guys think this is
[ __ ] news people
we don't give a [ __ ] there's one really
funny one of this guy named matt sarah
who's a ufc fighter oh i like that
that's the terrace
dude this [ __ ] was that i think
like caesar's powers or something and
this guy was acting belligerent at the
buffet he's drunk yeah
crazy bro just wildin what does it mean
to be belligerent
just like arnold schwarzenegger
throwing tongs everywhere i paid for his
that's the joe chilly one right there oh
my god bro you [ __ ] that guy's done
wait take that back i barely i don't
even see that one guy needs to find it
let me find it clean let me find a
cleaning because the news is yeah and
then matt sarah is like he's talking
this guy this drunk guy at the buffet is
going crazy and the master just holds
him down like the calmest guy you've
ever seen oh at the bar yeah yeah yeah
controlling them and the guy's like i'm
gonna kick your [ __ ] ass and that's
just like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
just like chill super calm dude i'm
gonna kill you yeah yeah you're just
sitting on top of them we're just gonna
wait till the police come it's all right
it's tight
that's a real g right there do you have
the idea you just do for real no
what about a wife talks back all the
time yeah bro i'd be [ __ ] putting her
in my guard and just holding her all the
time no i've never had to do jiu jitsu
you never chug tiff out no no have you
ever
ever had to fight on the streets no
really no i'm too much of a [ __ ] you
never fought on the streets not like
that here it is so that guy apparently
has been talking [ __ ] to joe chilly and
everyone at the bar the whole night
that's not a buffet bro oh this is a
different difference
i'm so upset about that
i wanted to see someone act like a fool
at a buffet i get it
oh he's kind of one too that was that
was like full power not even like
holding back you know that's not holding
back dude and he just walked away like
it was nothing criticized that technique
[ __ ] yeah what are you going to say
about it honestly his hooks could have
been tighter his elbows down here
like he knows he's like so if you have
elbow up then you have the power that
transfers to the fist right
his elbows were down so he was actually
hitting him like 10 in my opinion yeah
10 percent and he started with the right
instead of the left but
that's not a technique you want to hit
the jaw sideways versus just like knock
it into your brain whatever works really
whatever gets the job maybe that's his
technique i think he should have used
open hand because i did taekwondo in
virginia when i was a kid all i know how
to do is like [ __ ]
oh yeah
if i'm never in a fight dude i'm gonna
[ __ ] it up that way that's intimidation
bro that was like that was like stop
[Applause]
i don't want to hurt you i'm just going
to disarm you
three minutes later
i am
that's called forms dude it's the only
thing you [ __ ] learn apparently
what is it
where's your teacher's name his name is
jeremy actually he was like he's
actually a legend
yeah in performance martial arts like
the board breaking stuff yeah what a
waste uh you know you're thinking you're
like what a wait i think he was the guy
that added music for his pride
i think he was the guy that invented
adding uh mortal kombat to your
katas yeah oh that was my first song for
my first form mortal
battle of atlanta 1997 open forums
musicals that was my first song you did
sport karate karate and i was like oh
[ __ ] like i have the sixth song do
mortal kombat cut to the every guy using
mortal kombat mortal kombat and i was
like the sixth person
it's like
were you like [ __ ] that's my song you're
the part where i squeeze mortal kombat
the is i do a jump and i do a splint and
go ah
like everyone did that and you thought
you were so original so i had like half
fast i was like
[ __ ]
you couldn't do it
like
[Laughter]
dude
[Laughter]
what i want to know if they play that
song six times in a row how are the
parents just sitting there there's no
way they're just sitting there you have
to [ __ ] just bro we're all eight no
we're all asian so like
the song is so hype dude
oh man
it might be the most prolific song
there's that song and a lot of people
use sandstorm
the silver nunchucks so from that choice
or the worst everyone doesn't build up
it's like
dude anthony's about to hire you for the
kids dude he's about to ask you to join
you're like yeah and then i jump and i
go
he's like waiting for
it's actually funny that we actually
danced to this song like a couple weeks
ago
what was the routine like well that
should be how is it different than his
oh his is clearly worse
clearly worse what are you guys doing
martial arts movement [ __ ] no we just
did this thing where we asked our fans
we're like we'll call you after anything
right now and then that's when we found
out our [ __ ] fans were old as [ __ ]
because they were like sandstorm was
like what the [ __ ] or you think they're
trolling both sounds
because i don't think a young kid is
going to troll sandstorm oh true it was
kind of wild as if there was a there was
actually a pedophile in my taekwondo his
name was sandstorm
i'm serious and my mom like because he
was always cool to us obviously because
i'm a kid
wait how old was he and how old were you
guys he was like in his 20s and like i
don't know i was like seven years old or
some [ __ ] is he the same guy that she
caught last time or she's always
catching this pedophile no she's he's
the same guy that she count years later
i thought she was good at catching
pedophiles no she only caught one two
years later she really got one
i wonder how many got away
uh but she only got the one but yeah
enough so she so she used to be really
overly nice to us obviously because i
was the cutest kid had a great ass too
and and so he uh y'all got that
taekwondo ass that's true you got an
athletic butt yeah so then he um
years later my mom's like looking at the
newspaper and she sees that he got
arrested for like like diddling a kid in
our neighborhood or like next to our
neighborhood the neighborhood over billy
is such a [ __ ] worthy it's right now
like can you give me the scientific uh
description you raped him anthony he
raped him jesus
is that what you wanted to hear your
monster wait so this dude was also a
practitioner so like he's doing the
[ __ ] gilbert dance
and then the whole time he's just like
looking at all the kids like their
instagram models and [ __ ] like taekwondo
classes or martial arts classes is kind
of a hot spot for a little pedo we were
talking to this guy called from a dojo
dog there was a famous jiu-jitsu place
who apparently like i think it's in
florida or something
these [ __ ] got in trouble for
one of their coaches was like
[ __ ] around with their students like
grooming 12 year olds like diddling and
having relationships with them when they
were like 17 and 16. and they're
coaching since they were 12 and this gym
has a hotline
instead of if you've been abused by a
coach there or sexually assaulted you
would call the hotline of this gym
who is housing this coach
instead of going to the police and they
were saying like yeah call the hotline
call the hotline they're like oh you've
been touched called the hotline yeah but
it was just his [ __ ] voice owner bro
he's the owner of the [ __ ] gym like
okay let me uh come to my house let's
talk about it yeah it's like bro oh wait
so it's it's not the the owner is
different from the coach
yeah the owner so the coach is the
diddler and then the owner the owner is
the guy that's [ __ ] covering it up
cover-ups dude everywhere you go he's
like young man have you ever tried
sangria
it's from yeah
it's from costco but it's from spain i
heard
yes that little boy was me hi i'm
sangria
yo in the 80s right there was this
[ __ ] karate master that um diddled a
boy right and then um on on a [ __ ]
karate camp trip and then when they got
back
the cops were about to apprehend this
dude at the airport
and the dad came out and [ __ ] blasted
this dude in the [ __ ] stomach right
in front of the cops that's pretty
baller that's gangsters because back in
the day there was no tsa right you just
walk into the [ __ ] airport when you
went to go pick up his son and then when
the cops were there to apprehend the guy
you just it's all on video because the
media was there everywhere you could see
this [ __ ] up like he just walks up and
he just boom boom boom starts blasting
and he goes diddle this [ __ ]
it was an 80s movie
and then the karate master died oh i
just love that there's nothing
i just love that there's nothing in the
[ __ ] world funnier to anthony lee
than kids getting diddled
careful boys
[ __ ] busted a gut joe's like dilled
this kid and
about to lose
[Music]
you